Welcome back, master, princess.
How many people are you?
That means... Translate or not.
How many people?
Just you.
So sad.
Follow me here to your table.
Oh, you're already there.
You self-seated.
Look at you.
You're so proactive, aren't you?
I mean, as you can see, it is a full house today.
You just got lucky.
We have many patrons of the spiritual kind.
Floating around here.
Yes.
Yes, yes.
Yup.
I'll be honest, guys.
I have nothing planned.
So...
This will be probably the most boring generic reveal you've ever seen in your entire afterlife.
Actually, no.
You guys are alive still, right?
Your entire life.
We're just gonna do it.
Are we?
Hold on.
I gotta stick with the story.
Master!
Princess!
Today, you will be served by a new maid.
Actually...
It's an old maid.
Wait, isn't that a game?
Anyway...
Wait...
Isn't that actually...
Old maid.
No.
She's a...
She's not old.
She's young at heart.
Well, she's also dead at heart.
But, um...
A new old maid.
Um...
Uh...
She took some medicine.
And it shrunk her.
Oh my god!
It was called...
MNTX4444.
It's a very...
It's an experimental drug.
On the black market.
Don't ask me why she took it.
Because she's just a big old dummy.
Yes, MNTX.
No, no.
Not MM.
MNTX.
MNTX4444.
Yeah.
Not FDA approved.
Absolutely.
Sounds lewd.
What are you talking about?
Conan would want to work...
No, no, no.
It's legally distinct.
Actually.
TMNT.
I think we're...
I think we're in the wrong place.
But anyway...
Um...
Please don't...
Comment on her size.
You know?
She's a little self-conscious about it.
And just frankly embarrassed...
That she...
You know...
Just willingly...
Drank some medicine.
Well, I wouldn't...
A drug...
I don't think I can say that it's drugs though.
Because...
I'll say it's...
Um...
A generic friend of Fox...
No!
But you know...
Just...
Just don't bring it up.
You know?
Just say it's...
You know...
Just say she is...
Just...
She's normal.
Okay?
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna let her in.
She might be a little...
A little goofy.
She's also gonna descend from the sky.
As one does.
Oh...
You see chocolate?
I don't even know why I'm acting like it's...
You know...
Not just my actual outfit.
It's not just me.
No.
I'm acting normally.
Like you can see me kinda...
Dancing.
YES.
I'm your maid And I descend from the heavens Look at my knees.
I'm very bouncy, aren't I?
OK.
I'm bouncing in every part that matters.
My whole body.
I'm bouncing only where it matters, you guys.
My dress!
Obviously.
Oh my god, it's a Powerpuff Girl!
I kind of do feel like a Powerpuff Girl.
Jiggle pudding.
What was that one?
The Giga Pudding?
Gigi Pudding.
Wiggle jiggle, yellow middle.
That's the best of what you are.
I love you, mint.
White and tender.
Surround the center.
Cozy sitting in your crackling shell.
I love you.
Oh, Pudding Pudding.
Pudding, Pudding, Pudding.
I can't remember.
Oh my goodness.
Actually, I can zoom in.
Okay, I'm just gonna show you guys.
Like I said, this is just the most...
This is the reveal of all time.
It's the reveal of all time.
The most reveal you've ever seen.
A reveal that you will remember.
Probably.
A reveal.
Fang?
I've always had a Fang.
Why are you guys so surprised about the Fang?
Jiggle pudding.
There we go.
That's a little bit better.
I'm here to serve you as your brand new mid.
We're happy about the Fang, not surprised.
I've always had a Fang.
Since day one.
Big face mint.
Is this big enough for you?
Big face.
You want the big face?
I'll give you the big face.
Nice.
A little bigger.
So you guys like my TV model?
It's pretty cute.
It has so many toggles.
I have so many things to show you.
Which are quite fun I think.
Your claiming.
That was close.
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
No nose.
Simba!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Got your nose.
Yeah, I actually don't have a nose here.
No nose.
Who knows?
But for real, I do have a nose sometimes.
I mean all the time.
Wait, what are you talking about?
Why did you say sometimes?
I said all the time.
I have a nose all the time.
Why did you say sometimes?
Why did you say that?
You know what?
Actually...
I have a nose all the time.
You can't say that I don't have a nose.
It's just really petite.
Okay?
And I'm small.
And so it's dainty.
It's a nose that everybody knows.
That everybody strives to have.
Actually, you know what?
Also...
When you say that I don't have a nose...
Actually, I mean...
What was I made for?
How does that Billie Eilish song go?
From Barbie.
What was I made for?
Cause I...
I have a nose.
This is you guys before stream.
She hates us!
What does a ghost need a nose for?
To smell you, my dear.
What am I?
The big bad wolf?
What is...
My... Oh, grandma.
Why do you have a nose?
Oh, to smell you, my dear.
To smell you, my dear.
You guys are waiting...
While you're waiting for me to start.
This is also you guys.
Hold!
I'm ready to cry!
When is she gonna start?
Is she gonna start on top?
Oh no, I don't think she's gonna do it.
I don't think she's gonna...
Ah!
Oh wait, she needs five more minutes.
Hold!
I feel attacked.
You should.
PN.
This is my PN.
She is mocking us.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
Don't leave because I'm gonna be doing some karaoke.
You guys won't leave the stream just because you've seen the chibi model, right?
You'll stay because you wanna listen to karaoke.
Right?
My eyes are so wobbly.
She's one second late.
Come to me.
Let's see.
I like when you're late.
The intro song is catchy.
You like my intro song?
Armin has no nose.
How does she smell?
Now, menti.
Do you have a tongue?
Oh wait, I think I do.
I thought I did.
Oh wait, no, I'm thinking of something else.
Thinking of something else.
Chibi Minto is not the only thing.
Well, the only thing today.
The only thing today.
But no, I don't think I have a nose.
No, I mean, a tongue.
That's just because I've been saying no's too much.
You guys have infiltrated my brain.
Obviously.
Let's see what else I have.
Oh, I have this as well.
I'm gonna scoot over a little bit for this.
Where... I don't know what to use this for.
But you can write stuff here.
What is Minto saying?
I'm saying something.
Minto saying... Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Wait, hold on.
What is Minto saying?
Oh no, Minto is angry and saying... she's got words to say.
Snaricon.
If I say snaricon...
Oh, snaricon.
I love snike.
I have a nose.
Ghost fact.
You eat nine ghosts a year while sleeping.
Is that true?
A ghost fact.
I'm speaking facts.
So maybe...
Maybe someday when I'm like doing a... like a yapping stream, I can put the topics of the stream in my little head.
Or something.
DNA of the soul.
So true.
But how does it taste?
Cute little chibi Minto love the fang.
Thank you.
Bogo is minted.
Very cute, small, wobbly chibi Minto.
Thank you.
I am very bouncy, aren't I?
Here's another one of a favorite.
She's saying you MF-er.
Yeah, you, you, you, you, you.
No.
My mouth is always wobbly.
I don't... I'm stuck on this puzzle.
I don't know what to do.
Actually, I have other stuff for when I'm stuck on a puzzle.
Actually, I have some expressions that I'm going to say for last that are my favorite.
But this one...
Ah.
Duh.
There's even more.
Oh my gosh.
There's so much.
There is so much.
There's like 30 expressions.
I'm not even kidding you.
There's like about 30 toggles.
So maybe I should get through this so that I can sing karaoke.
Oh my gosh.
I forgot an important thing.
Because I was playing Doom.
Hold on.
I'm going to just... I'm just going to kind of makeshift it.
I'm just going to kind of makeshift it.
Hold on.
Here we go.
I'll save this for later but...
Okay.
Sorry.
Like I said, this is the most makeshift...
This is the most makeshift outfit...
It's not an outfit reveal.
It's the most makeshift reveal you've ever seen.
What else was I going to do?
Oh.
I was going to...
Okay.
I'll save this one.
You guys seem to like dead eyes.
This is me when I become small.
I become small.
I'm too small.
This and an OL outfit.
You guys are such freaks.
This is me when I see how freaky...
You call me freak phantom.
You guys are the freak phantoms.
I believe.
Maybe.
When she sings cat song.
True.
But also...
I can be excited.
I can be so excited.
And...
Yeah.
Woohoo.
Yippee.
Yeah.
Yahoo.
Woo.
Look
at you guys.
You're so excited in the chat too.
Yeah.
But...
Also...
You guys...
You asked for what?
I'm just a baby.
Don't ask me to be responsible.
Oh, I'm die.
Thank you forever.
Ah!
Don't...
Wobobobobo.
Me playing...
That Outer Wilds DLC.
Wobobobobobo.
Thank you.
Like it a lot.
In fact...
Thank you.
Do you guys like it?
Do you guys like...
My...
Chibi model?
Hm?
Does it hit?
Does it suit?
Does it satisfy you?
Does it meet your satisfaction?
It's too cute!
Can you frog blink?
So many cute expressions!
I know, right?
Try it!
Yeah, yeah, frog blink.
Oh wait, actually I have the perfect thing for frog blinking.
Here, here, here.
My brain went puzzle.
Huh?
I don't get it.
I might be stupid.
Oh no.
Head empty.
My head is very...
empty.
When you...
When I...
When...
You're very jiggly for once.
What do you mean by that?
I'm wiggly?
I'm jiggly?
Yeah.
Let's see, what else do I have?
Oh!
This one?
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, me when I saw those...
When I see any Metal Gear merchandise, some...
My idol!
My Yoshi!
She just winked at me!
My Yoshi just winked at me.
This is heaven.
Maybe.
Don't tell our usual cute maid, but this maid is especially cute.
Your secret's safe with me.
But!
Also...
Wait, I forgot something.
Hold on!
I can...
I can also...
You guys are doing the heart emotes, right?
Me too!
Yeah, I'm gonna back up a little bit so you can see my body.
You can see me wiggle from side to side.
Yay!
This is when I'm delivering you all the moi moi energy!
Oishiku nare!
Moi moi!
Wait, hold on.
Redo.
Oishiku nare!
Moi moi!
Kyuuun!
Yeah.
Or...
Oishiku nare!
Moi moi!
Kyuuun.
You haven't been watching someone other than Minto recently, right?
Even the hearts are glitching out a little bit.
Right?
No...
There's someone other than Minto?
Exactly.
There's no one else.
Minto has a knife.
Just Minto.
It's not plastic.
It's real.
Why would it be plastic?
It's a real real real real real real real real knife.
Does the ace come back out?
Only watch Mint and Doki.
You know what, that's fine too.
That's fine too.
Okay, I'll put it away.
You guys like my knife?
What do you have there?
A knife!
No!
Just a ghost and her knife, you guys.
Oh my gosh, it's dangerously close to my eyes.
Will you cut our food for us?
Yes!
Of course!
That's why I have it, of course.
That's why I have it.
To cut your food.
Because you're little babies and you don't eat your steak unless it's cut into little tiny cubes.
With the assistance of me.
Obviously.
Let's see, what else do I have?
I have this one.
I'm not quite sure when to use this one.
Wasn't that the best story ever?
Actual Ikinari Steak.
So true.
Wasn't that the best story ever?
Isn't that the best story ever?
Anyway...
I've heard better.
Okay.
Name every better story.
AFK Toggles.
Oh, that's so true.
When I have gone fishing?
That's what you'll see.
Gone fishing.
Let's see what else I have.
Oh, of course!
I must have this for when everything is awesome!
Wow!
So many features!
Minto's cute little model is so cute!
She's so jiggly and wiggly and bouncy and fluffy and everything.
And she's so fun!
Oh my gosh!
It's just like having a new Vtuber!
I'm so excited!
Wow!
Yeah!
Squishy and new!
Oh my gosh!
So shiny!
It's like I've fallen in love all over again!
I'm gonna subscribe!
Hendrick, thanks for the...
Oh my gosh!
20 gifts!
Thank you!
Cowabunga!
Yeah, so this is what I'm really, really excited about.
Something!
It could be anything!
And let's see...
We have this one.
Shocking!
Big news!
Minto new model!
I mean, it's the same as her old model!
Just small!
She's so small!
She's like a little baby!
She looks like a marketable plushie!
Not yet!
Did you just...
Oh my god!
Eyeball boy, did you just gift one membership?
Thank you!
Let's see...
Gosh, there's so many that it's hard to...
It's hard to...
I showed you this one...
Yeah...
Oh, and then this one...
I think you guys will really appreciate this one.
It's quite subtle, so let me know if you see it.
Because...
You know...
Working as a maid is a...
It's a whole lot of work.
It's a whole lot of work, you know?
It's a...
Mint Vantovar...
The...
Yeah, but you know...
It's honest work.
And it's not so bad.
It's just, you know, I could use a little...
I could just...
I could...
Let me just take a...
Let me just take a nap here, okay?
Are you still here?
Break's over?
Oh, yes.
Thank you.
I got my 20-second break in for the day.
Back to my 12-hour shift.
All right.
Yeah.
But it's okay.
You know why it's okay.
You know why it's okay?
Because when I work...
I make all that money, baby!
I'm...
I'm a hard worker for that cha-ching, cha-ching.
Cash, money, money, money, money!
Yeah!
Cheapy, tired Minto is my two-spirit animal.
I think...
Should I be concerned or...
Wow!
A gold coin!
Money!
This is me when I go gambling in Vegas, everybody!
This is all my eyes can see.
All I can see is the dollar signs.
All in, baby!
All in!
I got a fortune!
Vegas!
Gambling!
This is me!
Deal or no deal!
Loads of money!
See you, thanks for the bar!
Gifted!
Yeah!
Here come the money...
Let's see...
So I showed you basically almost all the expressions.
I have just two left or three left that I kind of want to save because they're my favorite.
But also, when we're just kind of chilling here, sometimes at maid cafes, you can also buy your maid a drink to drink with you.
So, well, you guys have already donated, so thank you for the drink.
Nothing like a cup of joe on a Sunday morning reading the paper.
Still a little hot.
Yeah, this is super comfy, isn't it?
It's pretty comfy.
Tired eyes plus coffee.
Oh, guys, it ain't easy being cheesy.
Oh, I'll tell you that.
You need a cigarette.
Stop!
Mondays, am I right?
Back to the daily grind.
But, you know.
Oh, money.
Tired money.
Oh, my God!
I hope I said your name right.
Thanks for the gift!
Thank you!
Yay!
So, yeah, I can hold a cup.
I can hold... I showed you the heart.
Oh, let me zoom out a little.
Yeah, it's very cute.
Thank you!
Thanks for all the donations and the gift and membership so far.
Good Minto morning!
Yeah!
The cup is literally me.
Good Minto morning!
And then I also have my knife.
But I also have, for later, when we do karaoke...
Ta-da!
Yeah!
And they match me.
They match my hair clip and my eyes and my ribbon.
But if you see me in concert, please use mint.
Yeah, please use mint, but I thought these colors also match me.
And you can see them pretty well, so...
Do Oshinoko baby dance.
Am I doing it?
Is it working?
But also...
If you're holding two pen lights, how did you make that clapping sound?
With my cheeks!
Duh!
And then...
If I'm playing a game, and I'm just like...
Okay...
I don't know what to do...
I can be like...
Hum hum...
Actually, I'm taking your order right now.
What would you like?
What would you like to order?
Have you decided what to order?
Burger!
That's the house favorite.
Cheese!
Anything else?
Omurice, please.
Omurice.
Extra salt.
Anything else?
Omurice, please.
I'm hungry!
Pizza!
Two number 9s.
Number 9, large.
Number 6.
Number...
No, extra dip.
Extra dip.
Number 7.
Okay.
Two number...
45.
One with cheese.
Oh, only one with cheese.
And a large soda.
Okay.
Can you repeat that?
I didn't write anything.
Instead, I drew a picture of a dog.
So, yeah.
I can make lots of lists now.
And lots of notes.
Your new model looks like one of those ice cream truck popsicles.
Except my face is not melting, right?
Okay.
Oh yeah.
And checky please.
Thank you for the pink!
Thank you!
So...
Oh!
Um...
Also...
When you're being bad...
I'm gonna call your mom.
Hello?
Actually, this is me checking Twitter.
Oh, hold on, I need a...
I need something...
This is...
What's this?
This is me, um, checking...
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, hold on, one second.
This is me checking Twitter.
Why did you post that?
Oh, it's so bad.
That's such a bad take.
Why?
Why did you post that here?
Oh my god.
Mobile games...
This is when Arona gives me only one gold.
Or one...
One two-star in a poll.
Thank you, Arona.
I love you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Don't tell mom I'm watching Mint instead of studying.
What?
Mom!
They're not...
They're watching VTubers instead of studying.
Get angry with the phone?
Get angry!
Terrible, terrible, terrible, terrible, terrible, terrible!
Everything about that is terrible!
Everything about this is terrible.
Terrible, terrible, terrible, terrible.
I'm angry because I spent so much money...
in Gacha.
Not really.
Just kidding.
But also...
Let's see...
Um...
We can do...
Oh!
This is the best poll ever!
I got three 3-stars!
Yippee!
Three SSRs!
Yeah!
But Mint, is it terrible?
Not anymore!
Looking cute, guys.
Thank you.
Me when I say capybara.
Yes!
Good job!
Satisfied.
But this one sent me enough.
Of course.
Oh, there you are!
Let me show you...
Your sword again.
I'm just gonna...
So clean...
The door is that way, Master.
Master.
The exit is that way.
The exit is that way, Master.
You didn't think you were going to leave without paying, did you?
For my moe moe service?
This is literally occupation.
I'll keep a maid ward.
I'll keep a maid ward here.
A last half-life 3?
Yes.
Being a maid is serious business, everybody.
Serious, serious business.
So yeah.
I have my crowbar.
Gordon Freeman.
And we have...
This is when...
Trying to riz you up a little bit.
M'lady.
Would you accept this rose?
That's only a fraction of...
As beautiful as...
You are.
Hold on.
Hold that on.
M'lady.
A rose for you.
It is only a fraction...
Of your beauty.
And your scent.
Do you accept?
My humble rose for you?
M'lady.
I'm going to throw up.
Please take my rose.
Please.
I feel like I'm on The Bachelorette right now.
It's only a fraction of your smell.
I mean.
Wait.
A fraction.
A beauty.
A beauty of your smell.
Hold on.
Gosh.
Wait.
Hold on.
I'm going to get this right.
It's only...
Your beauty is smelly.
Wait.
No.
That's not right.
You are...
You have a rose scent.
Oh gosh.
You guys.
I'm throwing.
Oh gosh.
Please.
Take my rose.
Are you a part of Team Rocket?
Team Rocket.
Blasting off again.
Anyway.
So.
When it is time for you to eat at the maid cafe.
Ta-da.
Just kidding.
It's my turn to eat.
It's my...
Mom said it's my turn to eat the omurice.
Less threatening knives.
See.
Yeah.
We have...
You're a...
Knife?
Serious knife.
Be afraid of this knife.
Thank you.
You're...
A soup.
Babu Minto.
We have this one.
Right?
And then fork and knife.
Very innocent.
Very round.
Sharp.
Round.
I dub thy...
Why am I a monto?
Don't eat me?
Oh.
Rice.
Nah.
I'm just gonna pretend I didn't read that.
Okay.
Anyway.
I'm putting the fork and knife away now.
You know what?
I'm gonna eat something that doesn't require a fork and knife.
At all.
Watermelon.
Yeah!
Because it's summertime, Watermelon is the perfect summer snack.
Am I right?
When will I ever use this?
Probably like the two times a year I eat watermelon.
It can also be used as a telephone.
Hello?
Ding!
Aw man.
It's about my watermelon's extended warranty.
Hang up.
Okay.
The last two expressions that I have that I wanna show you guys that are pretty silly.
They're mine and my favorites though.
Are we ready?
Oh my god.
I just realized I've been streaming this whole time without a noise key.
Sorry.
My bad.
If you heard anything.
Like me scooting around in my chair.
Okay.
Ready?
The first one.
Good.
Oh.
The most cursed part about it is I can't close my eyes.
Even when I close my eyes they're never fully shut.
I'm looking at you.
Minto Vegas sphere.
But then also.
Don't worry.
It gets even more dumb.
Minto...
Minto doesn't get it.
Huh?
Oh.
Just a box.
I don't get it.
I just don't...
Thanks for the two months.
Bye.
So these are my favorites.
Because they're so silly.
But also.
There's one other that I can do.
This one.
I think this one is where when I really mess up.
I'm sorry.
It's not... I didn't... I... It's not my fault.
It's... It's... It's... It's the government's fault.
You know?
I think.
Mint sweat collected.
Don't do that!
Those eyes could turn you into a perfect ice cream.
You're right!
Could just chew you right up.
Don't eat me!
I might have chocolate themed full ghost.
And I might be named mint but I'm not edible.
Probably.
I think so.
Anyway.
So yeah.
Are you guys ready for some karaoke?
What do you guys think?
Or do you think so?
What do you think?
Do you like?
10 out of 10!
Yippee!
Cute!
Very cute!
Yippee!
Thank you!
Remember
the basics of CQC, Chibi Minto.
I got you.
I just need a gun too.
But I at least have a knife.
Moe out of 10.
Yippee!
You need to give us a few months of mint.
Wait.
You need to give us a few months of mint as cute perms for this.
Gun is OSP.
Oh, you're right.
You're right.
Do you have a cellist?
I don't!
I was so unprepared for everything here.
Thanks for making me laugh.
Thank you!
What should I sing, you guys?
I need a microphone.
Do I have a microphone?
Oh, I do.
Kind of.
Hold on.
It's kind of funky looking, but that's okay.
Don't worry about it.
When you see it.
Oh, whoopee.
There we go.
Nice.
Hamtaro!
Okay!
We'll sing a Hamtaro!
Hamtaro!
Thank...
Hamtaro...
Thank you for the pink!
I loved all the different expressions.
Oh.
I can't wait to see you do some...
Thank you!
Thank you...
Let's see.
Hamtaro...
Okay!
Okay, time for karaoke.
I hope Ace Combat karaoke one day.
What kind of songs are in Ace Combat besides... well, the only one I know is...
Everyone get in a circle.
Yeah.
Everybody get in a circle.
Okay.
Let me test the audio.
Let me test
the audio.
Yay!
Actually, since I have now completed showing off the model, I'm going to put up my advertisements.
Kenny-san!
Thank you for the birthday gift!
Thank you!
I'll be honest.
I don't know that song very well.
But it's been requested before.
I don't know about his vocal music.
I'll look for you to play them.
Don't worry.
Thank you, Nan!
I'll look into... well, I will play them and then I will learn them.
Hashtag add.
Hashtag boomer.
Funky Monkey Babies.
It's been a while.
Oh gosh.
I'll try.
I'll do my best.
I think the...
It might be a little low for me, but let me try.
Let me see.
Let me see if I can try it.
Let me see if I can do it.
Freaky Meido Babies.
That sounds weird though.
Don't say it like...
Actually, don't say it like that.
Snow Halation?
Okay, I can do Snow Halation too.
Here, I'll make a list.
Next Snow Halation after Funky Monkey Babies.
I'm going to do my best to rap.
Ah!
Oh, sorry.
I messed up.
I pressed the wrong thing.
I meant to press the reverb and I accidentally pressed Snow Halation.
To-do-ke-te!
I accidentally pressed mute instead of... instead of reverb.
We are still small.
In the palm of my hand...
In this palm of my hand...
There's nothing.
It's raining and the wind is blowing.
But I won't give up.
But I don't want to give up.
I'm sure that someday...
We are still small.
In the palm of my hand...
In this palm of my hand...
There's nothing.
It's raining and the wind is blowing.
But I won't give up.
I'm sure that someday...
Where did it go?
I wonder...
Where has it gone?
Stop...
Why do I have a flash?
A
little pause... and we are back.
I'm a small selfish.
Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
I didn't let it finish.
I'm so sorry!
Shiny days?
Okay.
Shiny days!
Yes, yes.
Love the new model, it's so bouncy!
It is, it is, it is.
Rude me, though.
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry.
Okay.
I'm not just only taking requests, though.
So maybe don't spam them or anything.
Speedyfire, thanks for the vibe!
Gifted!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, my glow sticks!
You're so right!
I'm not quite used to the toggles yet, so I can't remember everything.
The more I use it, the more I'll get used to it.
So maybe just be a little patient for now with that.
If you're just like, gosh, she's not using any of her expressions!
It's hard.
It's hard!
Anyway.
Isn't this like the opposite of a summer song?
It's not like that.
You can make it feel like it just came down from the skies.
Ta-da!
A special season's color Makes you feel so excited.
When we first met, there was this ordeal in my mind.
A little pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
A little
pause...
and we are back.
If only I could change the lighting on these ones... to orange.
And we'll let that one finish.
Yay!
Um... um...
Shiny days.
I wonder if there's a karaoke about on here.
Oh, there is!
Nice, nice, nice!
Okay.
No guide.
To the other side of the light.
Right now.
The first step to the beginning.
Ready?
Shiny days.
A new wind.
I'll step on it.
Go my way.
Can you feel?
The sky is clear.
A brand new world.
Brought to you by the excitement.
Listen to the melody.
To the distant whispers.
If you let it resound.
Let's fly to the future.
Look,
if you look up.
The sky is full of clouds.
So happy.
Let's breathe in the air.
A small, natural miracle.
One by one.
Straight.
I'm grasping it.
A little courage is the trigger.
The world starts to move.
All right.
I can go anywhere.
Ready?
Shiny days.
Go my way.
Say your favorite song.
Feels so good.
Can you see?
The sky is clear.
Take to heaven.
The wind carries us together.
A brand new mind.
Please save your memories.
Let's overlap.
With your dreams.
Let's take a step to the future.
With a
smile like the sun.
Take it easy.
Let's relax our shoulders and spend every day Today and tomorrow, so it will be fine
Sing a song, let's sing together To the other side of the clear sky Can you see the glittering heaven?
The wind is inviting us to everywhere Shiny days, a new wind I step on the steps that seem to flutter and go my way Can you feel the sky that is transparent?
A brand-new world that is carried by a whirlwind Listen to the melody, to the faraway place If you make it sound to yourself Let's fly to the future Doo-doo-doo Bye!
Shiny days!
Maybe I'll do...
Hold on...
Maybe I'll do a few more songs?
I don't know what to sing!
Thanks for the claps!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Hmmm...
What to sing, what to sing?
I kneel...
Stop!
Why?
Why, why?
New romantic sailors?
New romantic sailors, sailors Since we are camping, do you know a laid-back journey?
I don't, I'm sorry, I'm sorry I could do a new rom...
Ah, thank you for the...
Just recently finished a great VN and started watching an anime I'm totally hooked onto its OST, you may know it It's so cool I would like to request either Gate of Stain or Hacking to the...
Hacking to the Hate I'm off to work, so best of luck I can do Hacking to the Gate Hold on, let me write...
What was it?
Hacking to the Gate And new romantic sailors Stay with me?
I can do that one too Stay with me Good choices everybody Let me see if I can find a karaoke of...
Hacking, Hacking to the Hate Hacking to the Hate This should work, let me make sure You sing like an ass
It's been a long time since I've sung this song, so I'll do my best It's been a while
Please keep your eyes on it Uhhh...
Uhhh...
Wait, actually, sorry I just realized Let me do this one instead Because I don't want to get...
I don't want it being...
Um...
Taken off of...
YouTube Hold on, I just have to check it OK, this is like a karaoke version Not like official karaoke You know what I mean?
I realize...
I think...
You guys...
I think for karaoke streams from now on...
I don't...
Oh, Jessie, thanks for the...
Thanks for the gifted I'm so excited!
Thank you so much!
For karaoke streams in the future, I might start doing them in shorts style because...
Actually, I didn't realize this, but shorts style... I don't know if it's shorts style streams, but at least shorts themselves are kind of...
They have their own rules when it comes to... when it comes to... what's the word?
Music?
And so, if I upload a music short, it says I can still keep it up and it's exempt from being blocked and stuff.
So, shorts are different with music copyright.
So I'm gonna test it as well with the shorts stream.
So maybe, maybe if we start doing the shorts stream, we can get around that.
Maybe, maybe.
So I'll try doing it.
So if you're wondering like, wow, I saw like so many other Vtubers doing it as shorts streams and I know that it's like...
I guess quote-unquote better for the algorithm too.
But maybe that's also why they do it.
I don't know.
But yeah, I'll sing Hacking to the Gate now.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Did you hear her?
Hold on.
I'll turn... Oh!
Pies!
Come here.
Stop scratching my tear.
Could you hear her?
Could you hear her going...
Come here.
I didn't realize you were in here.
You silly girl.
Silly baby.
Come here.
Come out.
Come here, pies!
Did you hear that?
That pathetic, pathetic sad meow.
What are you... What?
What are you rolling on your back for, you silly girl?
She's so sweet.
Cute.
Pies!
You can hear her, right?
Yeah.
Oh, just an update.
I guess on Butaro as well.
Ever since I've started the medicine for him, he has been doing so well.
He's responding to it so well.
He has been eating consistently.
He hasn't thrown up even once.
He's been doing really, really, really good.
He only goes under the bed a little bit.
But for the most part, he's been like super-duper, I think, feeling better.
And he's been more active.
He's been playing more with pies again.
So, I'm really happy.
So, yeah.
I think, you know, I'm not going to get my hopes up too much.
Just in case.
But I think things are good.
It was like almost immediate too that he...
It's so funny because every time I take him to the vet...
Every time I take him to the vet, the veterinarian is always just like, He is like the best cat.
I've ever worked with.
He's so sweet.
He's so kind.
He's so great.
That's good.
Thank you.
But when I had to go take him to get to the vet last time...
Because they had to do an ultrasound on him to test his...
To see if there was anything, you know.
Which, you know, they did find.
But they did find some stuff in his tummy.
But...
When I...
But they told me that I couldn't feed him the night before or the morning of.
And you have to keep in mind, before the medicine, he was already eating so little.
And so I had to take him to the vet and he was so hungry.
And then they told me not to pick him up until like after 4 p.m.
And so it was really late.
And I was like, well, surely they might have given him like a little bit of a snack or something.
But they didn't give him anything.
He hadn't eaten the night before or all day.
So the poor guy was starving.
And then when...
When I went to pick him up, they were like...
Mint, he was a little spicy with us.
He got hangry and he bit them.
He tried to attack them.
It's the first time he's ever, ever, ever...
My vet called my cat an unholy terror.
Yeah, every time I take him, they're like, he's such an angel.
He's so sweet.
Except this time, he was hangry.
And he...
He went after them.
Okay, let me let...
Oh, my goodness.
Let me let pause out real quick.
Let's sing Hacking to the Gate.
For reals this time.
For real.
Okay, let's see...disappear.
For reals this time.
What good was
A little pause... and we are back.
I really like this fire.
This maid is so cool, son of a bitch!
Nice.
Nice too.
Actually there's a song before I do New Romantic Sailors.
I forgot to sing it last time.
That someone requested Touhou.
And I have a Touhou song that I would like to sing.
One second.
I can grab it.
Actually, let me make sure that I can sing this.
Yes!
Okie dokie.
Cool.
I do have it.
I was like, wait a second.
I thought it was here.
I do have it.
Stop.
I don't think I can even... I don't even think I can sing that one.
Oh my gosh.
Begin!
I know you love singing Mary on a Cross, but are there any other ghost songs you like?
If you have any recommendations, I would love to know them.
Nico Nico Douga!
Maybe I can finish off with that.
Nico Nico Medley.
We'll finish it off with that.
I'll do New Romantic Sailors.
I'll do this Touhou song.
The New Romantic Sailors.
Then Stay With Me.
And then...
Oh!
Wata-shi no kare wa pa- You know.
Ok.
Wata-shi no kare wa pilot.
And then finish it with a Nico Nico medley.
Okokok.
This is from Touhou.
Last word!
A little pause... and we are back.
A little
pause...
and we are back.
I can't see your smile, I pretend I can't see your smile I realize the truth, I'm still searching for it For the sake of just one person, I risk everything What is a good love?
If I could bring back the time when I sacrificed everything I had If I could bring back the time when I sacrificed everything I had I wouldn't be able to be honest An eternal regret Tonight again, the red moon floats in the sky I gently close my eyes The tears I've hidden The words I've lost My breath trembles I just want love I love this part!
This is for Renemillia-sama!
I wish I could be her maid, too.
We meet, we confirm, we connect A miracle, we think of each other's dreams Like a foggy morning mist I'm looking for a nostalgic sound
Seeking for salvation I stretch out my fingertips The warmth I felt I remember the heat The screaming voice Overflows in the air The words I've lost
That was Yubisaki no Netsu from Touhou Last Word.
Yubisaki no Netsu.
Alright, next song.
Next song, next song, next song.
I'm glad you guys like the...
Like the Chibu Minto.
Ojo-sama love!
I know.
Praying for help me, Erin.
Erin, Erin.
Tashikete Erin!
Watashi no otsuki-sama.
Sakasamo no otsuki-sama.
Tashikete Erin!
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Maybe next time.
Maybe I should do a Touhou dedicated stream.
That would be kind of fun.
As long as I could get...
As long as I could get the karaoke for them, right?
Erin, Erin.
Da-da-da-da, da-da-da-da, da-da-da-da.
Is it JP only?
Somehow it became JP only songs today.
Somehow.
But that's okay.
That's a-okay.
I do have some stuff I gotta do.
I'll do later, so...
Um...
So, we...
I'll just do the songs that I have written down to do.
And then, um...
You know.
I can always do it karaoke.
Another day.
New
Romantic Sailors.
Sailors.
New Romantic Sailors.
Saikin kawari hajimeteru de.
Wow.
New Romantic Sailors.
Yato.
Yo.
I see the way of life, So for you.
There are many different worlds out there.
And some are just that invisible wall.
Knock Knock!
I start to discover, oh, he put away a star ship, Sailors habita sporting sp sparked, Sailors let's go!
Sailors let's go!
This is noell  This is noell  Visit to outreach and explore
Shook!
Sailors, let's go!
Mighty?
I mean, Jedi.
Yohane!
Mighty!
Oh, yes!
A little pause... and we are back.
A little
pause...
and we are back.
A
little pause... and we are back.
I want to live with you.
Neo-romantic Sailors.
New Romantic Sailors.
Sailors.
Neo-romantic Sailors.
Yeah!
Pre-recorded where?
Ah-ha-ha-ha-ha...
Oh, Neo-romantic Sailors.
Sailors.
This song is always so hype!
Could work for your voice.
I don't know either.
Who did those beautiful backings?
Pre-recorded scum.
Oh, that was the pre- Anyway,
let's dial it back a little bit.
And let's go...
Let's do, you know...
A little bit of a...
Back to...
Oh my gosh, hi Zuby!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you!
Okay.
We're going...
To you Yes, my love To you Yes, my love To you You
Watashi wa watashi Anata wa aneta to Man, these doors!
Yume iteta Sonna kimo suru wa
Sonna kimo suru wa Gray no jacket ni Mi oboe ga aru Kouhi no shimi Aikawarazu nano ne Show window ni Futari utsureba Show window ni futari utsureba Stay with me Stay with me
Thank you for watching this video.
Thank
you for watching this video.
Thank you for watching this video.
I'm not used to singing with this instrumental.
Love the performance!
Thank you, Robert!
Thank you, thank you!
Keep knocking them out of the park, queen!
I knew!
Thanks, Calvin.
Thank you, thank you.
That was...
...
Stay with me.
Alright, two more songs!
Actually, that's perfect.
Because then I end on ten songs.
Right?
Jay, thanks for the ten gifted!
And...
One...
Drag...
Thanks for the five gifted!
And...
Smashboo, thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you guys so much!
Thank you, thank you!
Absolutely beautiful performance!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Michael Jackson song?
Maybe next time, maybe next time.
I think next karaoke maybe I will do like 80s...
Karaoke...
Maybe.
English 80s and maybe Japanese 80s too.
Who knows?
But I'm not taking requests anymore.
Thank you though!
Thank you, thank you for wanting me to sing stuff.
...
I actually really like this song.
Let me make sure this one works.
Okay, it does.
I think it's good enough at least.
Okay.
Here we go!
Oh, I'm sorry, I can't read the...
Thank you!
Sorry, hold on.
I can't read it!
Hold on, let me pull up other lyrics with the footy gun or something.
Um...
...
I'm so sorry.
My Yoshi is illiterate!
I don't think I've ever sung this one on stream before.
...
I love the sky I love you, you love me
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank
you!
...
I love you, you love me
Well, guys, I really hope that you liked my scuffed karaoke.
And my TV model.
And...
Yeah, I'll use it.
I'll use it.
So...
Okay.
Last thing.
Last song.
Thanks for the no-no or summertime.
Thank you for saying the same with me.
Thank you, Chizoro.
Sorry.
I was late on...
On...
On saying that.
Oh, wait.
I think that one hasn't popped up yet.
I'm just some guy with a mustache.
Thank you.
It's everything I wanted and more.
Just half the size but twice the fun.
The main scientist did well with this one.
It is really cute.
Yay!
This song is actually quite long.
So it is quite the finale.
I've never...
I don't think I've ever sung it as a karaoke before.
So I'm gonna do my best.
And...
Yeah.
But this is the Niko Niko...
Niko Niko Douga Kumi Kyoku.
So it's a...
It's a big old medley of a bunch of old-timey...
Old-timey...
Old...
Older...
Not that old.
Um...
It's a...
Anyway.
Um...
This is the one, right?
Hold on.
Let me make sure I have the right one.
Actually, let me check the...
Oh, gosh.
It's kinda crunchy.
I think it's kinda...
Wait.
Maybe this one's not as crunchy.
I think so.
I think it's okay.
Hold on.
I'll check it.
Boomer!
Shut up!
I don't wanna hear that from you.
I can draw a straight line from me hearing Kumi Kyoku for the first time to this point right now.
Niko Niko Douga Love!
Oh, yes!
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh, gosh.
There will be scuff but that's okay.
That's okay.
I'll do my best.
It's so easy.
You like this kind of thing,
don't you?
Don't tell
me yamari yamari yaiya yamari yamari yamari yaiya The two of us look
straight ahead and go straight ahead.
It's
like a full-fledged trade.
All
you do is follow these paths and tenders of your gaming love.
All you do is follow these paths and tenders of your gaming love.
No matter who you are, no matter who your allies are, you can't stop
this indescribable wave of your heart.
Wait, where's the lyrics?
The lyrics are all over the place.
The lyrics?
If you can see my screen right now, it's so crazy.
The soul that can be seen through the eyes of the wise.
Aim for the future wherever you are.
I ran away because it was so bright.
I'm always weak.
From that day on, I haven't changed.
Even if I did, I haven't changed.
I haven't said anything.
I'm so frustrated that I'm talking to my fingers.
Where are you now?
What are you doing?
Are you in the place where this sky continues to go?
Will you smile at me as usual?
Now I just keep wishing for that.
I hate it.
Loving For whom?
For whom?
Can't be alive without you.
Why?
Why is it so embarrassing?
Don't miss you.
Love forever.
I don't know.
If I think about it, it will just fall apart.
You and
me.
Take away.
Kick around.
Wait.
Yeah.
I've done it when I was a child.
Beautiful
memories.
When it's a curry or something.
It's a good spoon.
It suits me.
Ultraman.
But now.
It's a mess.
Forget about it.
Like being chased by something.
I'm living every day.
The scenery is A black line.
A black line.
The lonely season is Graffiti.
The courage you gave me is A black line.
The lonely season is Dramatik.
I'll follow you.
What kind of pain?
In the darkness of the world.
I'm sure.
You are shining.
So
that my soul won't be broken.
My way.
It overlaps.
Now.
Let's go together.
It
should be mine.
Because it's a zero book.
Conclusion.
It's Monday.
But the mood is bad.
What should I do?
If I take off, it'll be good.
It's cute.
With all the people.
Gacha gacha cute.
Figure.
After.
With a more loud voice.
Let's scream out together.
Figure.
I've always been a friend.
Ten thousand years.
And two thousand years ago.
I love him.
Over 8,000 years.
I've missed you since I was a child.
I love you even more than I have ever loved you.
Since the day I met you, the music has been playing in my hell.
Pe-tan!
Un-to-ma-tsu Pe-tan!
Min-nan-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na Min-nan-nan-na-po-tsu Pe-tan!
Pe-paa!
Pe-tan!
Tsuru Pe-tan!
Ya-ja!
Min-nan naisuki-na-ni Koi
-wa yasashii kizu de
Peel -in-chin kazuku yoko ga Kiss my lips!
Ryousei-de dakishimete
Aishii -no o-yo-wa-ai
You are the prince of ten-e!
Sugii-ni yomi-washo onmyo-ji-ra-ka!
Te-u-sa Horu deshi Hon-jitsu-wa niko-niko-douga-ni Go-go-akusesu-wa arigatou-go-zai-masu Tai-hen moshi-wakere-masen-ga Kono-douga-wa oto-saito-no tsugo-ni-yori Go-ran-ni-naru-koto-deki-masu
Yay!
That was Kumikyoku!
Somehow, a little bit, a little bit.
Obviously, if you've never heard, if you've never heard the real Kumikyoku, um... niko-niko-douga medley, niko-niko-douga medley, I recommend you listen to it because it's so much more epic than when I did it...
Thank you, guys!
See you guys tomorrow... if I see you tomorrow...
If I don't, have a great rest of your... night.
Have a great rest of your week!
Well, see me once this week, okay?
You'd better not... you have to come see me once at least this week, okay?
...
RayVac, thanks for the buy gift...
Kitoto!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you!
Thank you guys!
I hope you liked the TV model!
And I will see you... later!
I will one
day sing that as a revenge.
What was happening was the lyrics that I was looking at...
and then the lyrics that I was following along with were different.
So it was tripping me up!
I was getting...
I was getting tripped up.
And then...
Hold on, let me show you the part that I was just like...
If you could only see...
I mean, the lyrics were...
were all the same...
Well, no, they weren't the same.
No, wait, hold on.
I'm trying to find...
Yeah, yeah.
This is what I was looking at...
when I was just trying to figure out the...
the dang...
I forgot something really important!
I'm going back.
I forgot something really important.
I forgot the...
You guys...
Hey!
You didn't leave yet!
I
would like to thank the person...
who drew and rigged my model.
I would like to thank them.
This is the credit.
Ta-da!
Hexose!
I hope that's how you pronounce it.
Or AKA 0x4682B4.
Thank you for drawing this...
and rigging it as well.
They did both.
And also...
When I...
When I got it...
When I got it commissioned...
I didn't even ask for any of these toggles.
Like literally...
Not a single one.
They just did everything themselves.
So...
Yes.
Definitely go follow them...
and support their work.
They live on Mars.
Yes!
So...
Thank you Hexose!
Thank you!
I feel so cute!
Okay, now get out of here.
Anyway, what was I saying?
Oh.
Let me show you what was on my screen.
Let me show you what was on my screen, when I was singing that part, why it was tripping me up so much.
Look at this.
Look at this!
What am I suppose to follow?
Oh.
This is just Niko Niko Doga medley thing, you know.
One of the lines.
Follow something, follow something.
Anyway, okay.
Thanks guys, thank you, I hope you liked the chibi model.
See you guys later.
Bye bye, bye bye, bye bye, bye bye.